[Musique]
dernière ligne droite de l'année pour
les 83 collèges de l'île et au collège
jean des sme c'est la présentation du
travail accompli en enseignement
pratique interdisciplinaire le pays ces
trois classes qui se préparent pour leur
spectacle sont des élèves de segpa
section d'enseignement général et
professionnel adapté prenons en charge
les élèves qui sont dans la difficulté
scolaire
suivront alors plus de la 6e à la 3e
avec
aux pressions des mêmes
des mêmes programmes que le collège mais
adeptes alors des fichiers c'est à dire
que notre objectif c'est vraiment
d'adapter tous les enseignements ont
besoin et au niveau des élèves
les amener le plus loin possible
[Musique]
ainsi là où on peut voir un simple
spectacle ce projet a une vocation
pédagogique transversale le conseil
départemental donc a en charge les
bâtiments des collèges et donc notamment
les plateaux techniques puisque ces
élèves surtout en 4e et en 3e
bénéficient de deux parcours
professionnel comme le proposent les
sols
[Musique]
c'est histoire géographie enseignement
moral et civique art du vivant du son et
du langage
le but est clairement de donner du sens
aux apprentissages et faire du lien
entre les différentes disciplines
la france amie remercie toutes les
classes c'est que la nuit est lourd mais
si le collège mendès et voilà on a un
vécu et que la réunion un véhicule et on
doit se respecter quand maladie c'est
vraiment bizarre parce que j'ai vu que
schalit kolb a jamais participé à
n'importe quel spectacle
je m'en fout toujours et aujourd'hui bas
comme par hasard j'ai aimé venir et j'ai
aimé vaincre ma part je suis fier parce
que là c'est pas c'est une classe qui
est beaucoup
jugé et ben j'espère que les autres cas
s'ils vont le respecter parce que là
c'est pas c'est quand même une classe
qui est enfin on est beaucoup en fait on
est beaucoup solidaire on s'entraide
beaucoup et wallace face aux autres
élèves de filières ordinaires ces jeunes
au parcours parfois difficiles avec des
difficultés scolaires persistantes ont
eu l'occasion de produire un moment de
bonheur collectif
[Musique]